as the show's over in miami
for ryan fitzpatrick it's to a time
of all the times for it to be to a time
yesterday
tua tagovailoa named the starter as the
dolphins start into their bye week they
got the rams on the other side week
eight
three and three are the miami dolphins
fitzpatrick has been far more fits magic
than fits tragic rough start to the
season but he's been very good since
then they're three-in-one over the last
four games christopher your reaction
when you heard yesterday that your
former colleague in new england brian
flores had decided to make the switch
from fitzpatrick to the rookie well i
mean i was surprised i was i'm not gonna
say i was like like oh my gosh i can't
believe they did this i i wasn't shocked
and i i'll say this for for this reason
over the last week i had definitely
thought about like okay we saw tua i
mean
we saw two of the other day but even
before that i step i i was thinking when
at what point do they infuse him in
there they're kind of getting into a
tough spot you know after they beat the
49ers and they go two and three you go
they look kind of good you know and
they're definitely going to beat the
jets so they're going to be three and
three
you know so there's two things here i
mean the first is they're going into a
bye week right so we always know that's
great for the quarterback and doing all
those things but i think the reason that
i'm not surprised or maybe not just
shocked is
look at their schedule
look at what is set up now the bye week
they got the rams but then they got the
cardinals the cho the chargers the
broncos the jets and the bengals i mean
they could be sitting here at eight and
four in another five weeks
and then what are you gonna do bench
ryan fitzpatrick or what then what are
you gonna do go ten and six and just get
in the playoffs and then abandon the
ryan fitzpatrick ship and kind of set
the narrative in a negative way for two
and next year well he's taking over a
playoff team why isn't this working i
mean like wait you mean like patrick
mahomes did well yes but
this is just this is different and they
don't feel the same way there it's a
little different that way you know there
this is that was already a playoff team
before that this is like oh they're
building something and i think they're
probably a little fearful of that and
then let alone the team is finally i
think in a spot where they go okay we're
pretty good let's put our quarterback in
there we're not putting them you know
with a work in progress where
everything's crazy around him and then
he can't be good either and it looks
like we've wasted a draft pick so i just
think the stars have aligned with where
they're at and where their schedule's at
to where they think this is the time the
time is now
and i was mainly giving you a hard time
by referring to patrick mahomes and
kansas city chiefs because it is a
different situation they were a
perennial playoff team under andy reid
and alex smith right and it was obvious
the moment that mahomes was drafted at
some point they're going to try to
upgrade they're going to try to go next
level oh and by the way it will work
next level
right and and let me tell you this
i still believe when the offense
sputtered in the 2017 season they should
have gone from alex smith to patrick
mahomes and if they had we all would
have been treated to the patrick mahomes
show
earlier than we were and who knows what
would have happened in the 2017 season
between the patriots and the chiefs in
the postseason if the mahomes experiment
had begun earlier but there's an
alternate universe out there where that
happened and again who knows what would
have happened if the chiefs had gone
with mahomes here because you're dealing
with a team that is bad far more often
than not they did bounce their way into
the playoffs in 2016 a quick one and
done at pittsburgh we don't even think
about that when we reflect on the last
decade of miami dolphins
if all of a sudden you get to the
playoffs with ryan fitzpatrick then
you're going to have a faction of your
fan base that wants to stick with him
right and it does start looking like a
wasted pic or it's too much pressure on
tuataga by lower so do it now
before everything starts to potentially
keep moving in a direction that makes it
harder to do it later aunt chris here's
the other thing too
we always
know that ryan fitzpatrick goes from
fits magic to fitz tragic it's just a
matter of time once everyone is bought
in to the fact that fitzpatrick is
really good
that's when he goes out throws four
interceptions and then we're like damn
what happened to that guy that was
really good so
you know the coaching staff in
miami yeah knows it's coming at some
point right let's go ahead and and and
walk away at three and three thank you
ryan fitzpatrick for getting us to 500
through six games that's right he's
gonna take it from here right i'm a firm
believer they should have just gone with
him from week one look the the
the moment you draft the guy in the top
ten
you know the the pendulum swung in 2008
when matt ryan and joe flacco both
started weeping flacco started week one
because troy smith got a case of
tonsillitis during training camp and the
preseason and the the ravens became
comfortable with the notion that flacco
could protect himself behind an
offensive line that wasn't spectacular
starting then the default has been other
than mahomes really
who's the other high
picket quarterback since 2008 that has
to sit for a year or two oh yeah it
doesn't happen anymore no so so get him
on the field let's see what happens
let's see if he can stay healthy let's
see if he's any good and you know chris
i'd be nervous as a dolphins fan
just
the historical statistical reality
that to pull three quarterbacks in the
top 10 and have them all end up being
really good doesn't happen
happened kind of in 2004 with eli
manning philip rivers and ben
roethlisberger robert berger was number
11 though
odds are
with justin herbert looking great and
joe burrow looking great odds are the
dolphins got the bust let's let's just
find out let's see what we got let's put
him on the field because it'll be better
next year you get him reps now he'll be
better next year instead of waiting
until next year to put him in the front
i think that's what their their main
thought is is it's not about this year i
mean yeah let's let's hope he can bring
us to the playoffs and we can be a
contender in all those things but you
know if they have to take a step back to
take two steps forward for the 2021
season i think they'll take that i think
that's what exactly what they're doing i
mean you explained it the right way yeah
ryan fitzpatrick he's had some success
he's done some good things we still see
fitz tragic a lot i mean he threw two
dumb interceptions in the game the other
day against the jets so yeah they know
what he is as a football player and they
were they were dancing the fine line of
oh man we're kind of getting good and
ryan fitzpatrick is playing some pretty
good football and this team's fun to
watch
where yeah he gets a little following
and
whether the the success of this year you
know makes more pressure on tua or
whatever else or if they decide to do
this a little later on down the road
when maybe they were five and five or
something like that or even a better
record at six and four that would be
really difficult that'd be hard to sell
to your locker room if they got down
here and it was you know six and four or
seven and four or something like that
and then they pulled the the cord man
right now is the time to do it for tua
for the organization the team is ready i
think they probably didn't start him
week one because of the injury and they
just wanted to make sure he they took it
slowly and he was physically hitting on
all cylinders before they put him out
there in harm's way
and it makes sense from that standpoint
it really does and we'll see where they
go we do like we said maybe he can
maximize more out of this team this
offense and uh with his own ability than
a guy like fitzpatrick can they're
hoping so it's just does it happen this
year or will it happen next year
another important factor we have yet to
discuss as it relates to this decision
to go from fitzpatrick to tonga viloa
we're not privy to what's happening in
practice well we don't see what two is
doing and we don't know what the mood of
the locker room is yeah you know yeah we
we can look at this and say this is a
move for the future
there are going to be guys in the locker
room that say screw the future we got a
pretty good team we want to win
definitely yeah and and and you're
either risking that blowback or those
guys are on board with it because they
know
two is the better option if you want to
win now well that could be a very real
possibility that might have got to the
point to where down in miami 2 is
starting to you know open up some eyes
on a daily and weekly basis the people
are starting to go wow whatever that is
and yes i think your point about you
know ryan fitzpatrick doing well things
like that are there plays and reads he
misses and leaves meat on the bone every
now and then
i'm sure there is you know that i mean
that's that's the great story about alex
smith and patrick mahomes you know
that's i love to say that hey they were
the number two seed he was the number
one quarterback in football quarterback
rating why would they ever change
quarterbacks why would they have ever
drafted oh that's right because numbers
can lie there could have been a million
other plays that were there to be had
that patrick mahomes would have took
advantage of and alex smith didn't and
that could be a very real possible part
of the situation too to where they go
hey it's good from fitzpatrick but we
think we can do more with this guy we
might again have to take a step back as
he kind of gets a feel for the league or
whatever but again i think the greater
good and what they're going to have to
try to sell to their team is their best
team that they can possibly be will be
with tua at quarterback it just might
not look like that the first week or two
when he gets in there
three years ago when mahomes was on the
bench travis kelsey was on this show
and the issue came up of the things
mahomes is doing in practice yeah kelsey
was over the top effusive and that's one
of the reasons why i'm thinking
well as this offense sputters and andy
reads the one that stood up and took the
flak forward it's not the quarterback
it's me and it really is amazing in
hindsight that he
allowed smith to to have that final
season to take it as far as he could
and yeah they got to the playoffs but
they didn't come close to the ultimate
goal right
i really do i can't help but wonder
and and i wonder
how the locker room felt about that now
look some of those guys were there two
years later when they finally get their
super bowl rings but there may have been
some guys there in 2017 thinking we got
a shot at getting our super bowl ring
now and it's a testament to how andy
reid controls his team you know some
coaches are going to have a problem in
the locker room in a situation like that
others aren't reads a guy who's not
going to have that problem but we'll see
if brian flores has that problem we just
don't know and here's another thing we
don't know chris here's
we can't assume
that this is a decision of the coaching
staff we will and it probably is
but you may be getting some pressure
from above well put two out on the field
yeah because i heard back at the time
tua wasn't a coaching staff pick tua
wasn't a gm pick right tua was an owner
pick that was the fallback when they
couldn't persuade the bengals to do a
deal that would have allowed the
dolphins to get jill burrow tua became
the guy for the miami dolphins yeah well
i heard the same talk i know we had a we
had a lot of conversations on the show
and privately back then that we felt
like that was going on and we talked to
some people that we trusted that we felt
like yeah the owner was very involved in
the pick and certainly and wanted to get
that you know marquee name and you know
face of the franchise type guy you know
i'll go back to something i think you
said a little earlier you know there's
always a bust in the top ten or whatever
there's we got two guys that we've shown
to be good well i think that's put
pressure on the situation too
i mean joe burrow yeah he's taking a
beating and they're not winning a lot of
games but every game he's impressive i
mean again last week i know they lost
but they're not good but he's like he's
one of the shining you know beacons of
that football team right now so i think
between that and then they see justin
herbert and they it probably start okay
these guys they're not overwhelmed
they're ready our guy went to alabama i
mean he's ready we know that let's not
be afraid to throw them out there and i
think you know i think that probably
nudged them a little closer to making
this decision as well
yeah i mean
those factors cannot be overlooked
because as we see other young
quarterbacks do well
the owner if he was involved in any way
and one of the privileges of being a
billionaire is you don't have to tell
people directly what you want them to do
there are ways to drop hints and if
people want to continue to be employed
by the billionaire they will act on
those hints
now's the time to find out because you
know what
it's not like the fan base is going to
get upset and i'll come to the games i
hardly have any fans there anyway
because the pandemic good point let's
build some excitement for next year
let's see what tua can do let's find out
whether or not we have a guy that's
going to come out and be durable that's
the one big thing i'm concerned about
with tua yes i want to see if he passes
the eyeball test but when he suffered
the fractured hip last year at alabama
and i started talking to gm's about what
this does to his draft stock the one
thing that stood out to me
three lower leg injuries three lower
body injuries in three years at alabama
will he be durable as a mobile
quarterback at the next level when he
has a lower body injury every single
year at college where even though the
sec
is the cream of the crop that rises to
the top
boom bingo well done
thank you very much the nfl is a
different ball game all together yes and
yes and and and and you know the one
critique you've had of tua
he he doesn't avoid contact and he takes
a lot of awkward hits and you start
taking awkward hits from nfl players and
you're not going to be playing for very
yeah that's what's scary it is i mean
yes sec is amazing it's got more nfl
defensive lineman than any other
conference it's not even close but
there's still a lot of defense alignment
in that conference that will never play
in the nfl and there's still a big jump
to put to what you're saying i mean when
you get on the nfl field the defensive
ends
are all lsu you know it's just it's
different it's they can all fly they can
all go you're gonna you have to be a
special type of runner he was a good
runner in college not special and then
yes he plays small
and has you know a little bit of that
recklessness that listen we've talked
about whether that's carson wentz or
josh allen a little bit to where the
play just will never die for him and he
might hold the ball to the very last
second and because he's a smaller guy
man he took a lot of big hits and he's
not as fast as like a carson wentz or
josh allen so that's what i do worry
about i really do so we'll see what it's
all about he looked comfortable with the
game last week looked cool in the number
one i like the way he looks you know i
love a lefty quarterback out there
that's great to see
um but i did have my questions about him
at alabama i did thought he was really
good but you know their offense is still
really good there right now they're
still just tearing it up going up and
down the field and i just want to see it
was it him or was it maybe more them and
that's where i kind of had my questions
and i want to see is it something that
will point to tua being the guy who
doesn't work out did they get the wrong
guy because justin herbert is
flourishing even though the charges are
one and four and herbert's yet to win a
game there are other ways to determine
whether or not a guy is right done
herbert's clearly getting it done right
we'll know quickly whether or not two is
getting it done and he does get the
baptism by fire
sunday november 1. oh baby los angeles
rams coming to town now i don't know if
that counts as bingo but we are going to
refer to the miami dolphins schedule
here you mentioned it earlier
after the rams they go to arizona which
is not going to be an easy
win
but they're not they're not a team
you're right off not after what they did
to the 49ers in santa clara a couple of
weeks ago right then it's the chargers
how about that justin herbert and two
are on the same field competing with
each other to justify who's better at
five or six at the denver broncos not a
gimme but but not not like going to
kansas city and then at the jets there's
a win the bengals we got the round robin
here i know now too bad herbert wasn't
playing when the chargers and bengals
got together in week one but two is
going to get to face both of these guys
yeah over the next several weeks and
then they do have the chiefs the
patriots the raiders and the bills to
end the season but hey look
i'm not going to write them off when you
look back at who they've beaten that's
right the 49ers you know no no the the
jets and the jaguars okay but to beat
the 49ers yeah at a time when we thought
they're gonna find a way to work through
these injuries they're you know they're
they're they should win the games that
they are supposed to win
43-17 that got our attention i'm not
ready to write the dolphins off but i
think that that they understand it's
about laying the foundation for next
year let's see what we can do this year
but the more reps he gets now the better
he's going to be in the future give him
the opportunity to let the game slow
down don't throw him into a week one
next year
hopefully it'll be a full stadium and
and it's and you're just wondering and
yeah if you somehow pull an inside
straight and get the seventh seed and
you have people saying what happened to
fitzpatrick it just it doesn't it
doesn't set off it doesn't stop possible
circumstances exactly right you put the
guy with a lot a lot of pressure on him
i mean the microscope would be on him
it's as soon as they lose a game they're
like oh well should they have drafted
him that should they have stayed with
fitzpatrick they're one in one
i mean i don't know if he's the face of
the franchise so they don't want to hear
that talk you're right and i think to
your other point too you know you don't
want to be into week one next year
starting your first game and playing in
the nfl it's just not good the nfl
quarterback i know you've heard me say
it a million times it's just
you can practice all you want it's just
nothing's gonna get you ready until you
get out there in a real game it's just
there's a it's different it doesn't
matter the game is never perfect on the
on the real field as compared to
practice people tearing your head off
having to adjust on the fly
nothing beats being out there and
getting that experience and mike you
know the other thing you talk about like
with the schedule yeah it's it's great
because you look at those teams you know
you talked about yeah they beat the
49ers and the other two wins were kind
of the you know jacksonville and the
jets but damn they got impressive losses
that's that's i think the thing i'm i'm
intrigued by or you know like like opens
up my eyes hey they were tough on the
patriots they were tough on the seahawks
and the bills game was a shootout back
and forth and not this game was a
shootout back and forth and not to say
the bills are the best team in the afc
but they're still good football team so
there is something here and you know bye
week
you got the rams
you know i i think i think they looked
at it and went oh okay yeah the rams we
know they're a little bit better than us
no doubt but i think flores thinks his
team probably matches up really well
with them you know you saw what the
giants did to the rams a few weeks ago
patriots ex-patriots
coach up there patrick graham the
defensive coordinator of the giants
brian flores is going to have those same
type of new england type of scheme that
we saw new england shut down the rams in
the super bowl with and he's got really
good corners and those type of things as
well and the other thing that i think is
a little bit beneficial with the rams
the rams are really simple on defense
mike so it's a game where
you know he's not going to have to do a
lot of mental gymnastics and be like
what i don't know what coverage this is
i don't understand this this is some
crazy baltimore ravens everyone's
standing around the rams are kind of
like
nope here we are
it's covered three it's man-to-man
quarters coverage that's it can you
block 99 okay that's that's all we're
we'll see what happens and that kind of
is is helpful for a young quarterback
too to play a defense like that
what will you be looking for november 1
rams dolphins as we're watching all of
the games unfold when tua goes out for
the first time what do you be watching
for to see whether or not he's ready
for this kind of competition especially
with not just 99 but also jalen ramsey
on the other side yeah no doubt yeah
well i you know the first thing and i
think you would agree here is we're i'm
big into the look test right off the bat
just how does he look how does he look
in the pocket with everybody around him
you know what's his presence on the
field does he bring a little edge and
attitude to the football team what what
is it exactly there that he brings and
then yeah i want to see
what his arm looks like in an nfl
environment i do he threw to a lot of
wide open receivers in alabama i want to
see him like can he when he's got to
step on the pedal a little bit it's
tight coverage on a 15 yard out route oh
i want to see can he can he zoom it in
there you know what does he look like
running around as far as his size
and his movement that way you know those
are things i'm not sure about you know
baker mayfield that was my big concern
about him coming out in the draft and it
you know it's coming true that's what
scares me big baker mayfield the pocket
gets around him he can't see anything
downfield and he panics and he looks at
the pocket and then you don't know where
the throw is going to go i mean he'll
just throw it so those are the little
things i worry about with two and that
i'll be watching for in that that first
game
yeah i'm looking forward to it and i
think they're doing the right thing
whether they make the playoffs or not
whether they win another game or not
this is about building for the future
and this is about seeing what you have
do you have your franchise quarterback
they really haven't had one
since dan marino they've tried yep they
had chad pennington for
a year where it all fell together and
they won the division the season that
tom brady suffered a torn acl week one
and still the patriots went 11-5 but the
dolphins won that division when
pennington landed in their laps because
the jets went out and got brett favre
other than that they've had a hard time
developing quarterbacks they've had a
hard time identifying competent
veteran quarterbacks they could bring in
they thought they had something in ryan
tannehill they gave him an amazingly
long amount of time and it has to be
killing them and maybe this is a fact or
two chris right it's got to be driving
them crazy that the guy they invested
six full seasons in
is now tearing it up for the tennessee
titans and looking like one of the best
quarterbacks in the nfl yeah well you
know hopefully they learn their lesson i
don't think the dog this dolphins regime
is going to make these mistakes you know
they never really set ryan tannehill up
with
anything to be successful with so what
do you know again what do you expect
it's a little like the jets right now
they're in the similar spot poor adam
gase he didn't build either one of those
teams but he's same thing like hey sam
darnold's good but how good do you think
he's going to be i mean who who who's
there is going to make him great or that
offense great and it's it's the same
thing they did to ryan tannen when you
draft one of these top 10 quarterbacks
you know the next thing you have to do
is give them a supporting cast to
justify the quarterback in the top 10
make your investment look good
get people in football to go oh your
first round pick looks you know your top
ten pick looks good get the media and
the public perception around that pick
going in the right way that is the right
way to do it and you know that's where
they messed up now right now they got it
i mean with preston williams and devonte
parker they got a little run game going
mike gaseki is starting to show like
he's one of the best pass receiving
tight ends in football they got these
young offensive linemen they're kind of
doing good so they've they've got the
support already here now and now it's
like okay now the quarterback's up to
speed he's healthy here we go let's see
if he can take off with the rest of the
offense here and show us something and
at least i think they got the formula
the right way for it to be successful
we'll see whether whether or not it
works
wouldn't it be fun to do a little mad
scientist thing and start moving some of
these quarterbacks around oh i think
about it all the time
i thought of it when you mentioned
darnold mahomes just flip flop those two
right put sam darnold in kansas city put
pac-man homes with the jets and let's
see what happens yeah right i still you
know mahomes would still do amazing
things but yeah would they would they be
much better i don't know maybe they're
one they've been one game right now
maybe they win one but yes they beat the
chiefs
but that's it it is i do the same thing
it is a fun exercise and i think there's
you know something to be said about that
as awesome as mahomes is
we you know sometimes i do feel like we
forget you know even that was my thing
with like troy aikman the other night a
little bit he kind of was talking about
josh allen and oh he finally got some
weapons and i wonder well yeah my home's
always had weapons you know it's that's
not always fair he had the best tight
end in football one of the best
receivers in football one of the best
play callers in football and that helped
them show what he really is and can be
as a player and now he's the best player
in the sport
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports